thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
steadymd lets you maintain a meaningful
long-lasting relationship with the
primary care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99 dollars a month with no
other fees or copays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started it's important for
us to be
realists and not idealists we have to be
cautiously
optimistic and pragmatic not
delusionally
utopian and in that vein it's important
that we all understand as we think about
the next months and certainly the next
couple of years
that there is simply not going to be the
unity that joe biden campaigned on and
called for
in his inauguration speech we've talked
about this a little bit more and later
today we're going to be looking at
one piece of why which is that thanks to
the cult of trump there are now people
in positions of power like lauren bobert
like madison cawthorne like marjorie
taylor greene
who don't know anything they are simply
political characters
playing roles they are not lawmakers
they are not thinkers and unity isn't
part of the character they've been hired
to play and by hired i mean voted in why
by wacky trumpy republicans in november
of 2020.
that's one side but there's another side
to this
which is that joe biden is going to do
things that will disgust
not half of the country but a large
enough
portion of it that a contingent of
republican elected officials
will stand in the way and say no no
matter what
uh we actually are seeing amazingly
significant approval of for example joe
biden's
first week five days on covid and we'll
talk about that a little bit later
but even significant approval like 70
which in this country is incredible it's
almost unanimous approval
for the standards we have here the 30
percent that hates it
are represented by some of the most
radical members of congress
and so there is not going to be unity
conservative rich lowry wrote a piece in
politico called
no there won't be unity and his sub
headline
explains his take on why which is quote
on substance biden is not going to
pursue a consensus bipartin
bipartisan agenda but a progressive one
i don't know that i'd characterize
biden's agenda as progressive
it's certainly to the left of recent
democratic presidents
but what rich lowry is saying is that
joe biden is going to do things that the
right will never accept
joe biden wants unity around us deciding
as a country
to follow science instead of cartoonish
denialism on covid
30 or so percent of the country doesn't
want that this isn't the both sides
thing merely differences of opinion
imagine if 30 percent of the country
said we don't agree with the laws of
gravity
you'd say okay well you're going to end
up getting a lot of bumps on the head
and people falling out of buildings but
the idea of ignoring something that
simply is
you don't really have a choice and joe
biden is going with
reality on covid and about 30 percent of
the country doesn't accept it so you're
not going to get unity
joe biden is doing things that are going
to be characterized as
stirring the pot literally the term rich
route lowry uses in the politico piece
last week i played a clip
fro for you from fox news of anchor
ainslie earhart saying joe biden called
for unity
and yet he did executive orders that go
against how trump governed
well that's a framework where unity is
quite literally
impossible now unity doesn't have to be
we agree with joe biden on everything
unity
should be biden won yes he really did
win
uh many of them don't accept that but
okay but biden won
unity can be since biden won let's try
it
let's not actively obstruct everything
joe biden tries to do and let's evaluate
where we are in six months
empirically but they're not going to do
that and so what republicans are already
saying
there won't be unity because joe biden
is doing stuff
they are right about half of it which is
there won't be unity but it's more
because of the country being
divided culturally to such a degree
one side wants to get actual experts and
scientists involved in
solving some of the biggest challenges
we have the other side wants cartoon
character right wingers
who want to bring guns on the house
floor and
feed every false conspiratorial notion
they can come up with
unity truly isn't possible in that
scenario but it isn't because joe biden
is doing things biden's president
that's what presidents do when they get
to work when they don't go golfing
twenty percent of the time
they get to work and they try to do the
things they campaigned on but that's not
the story being told on right-wing media
which is another reason why there won't
be unity
i'm not challenging fox news's right to
exist
i'm not saying news max should be pulled
off the air i'm pointing out that
they foment the lack of unity by putting
out nonsense like
biden doing the things he promised to do
is
divisive joe biden doing the things he
ran on doing which got him
elected is now being called a divisive
action
and understand that with that as your
starting point
the possibility of unity doesn't exist
because you're not
dealing in actually evaluating policy
you're not dealing and saying oh joe
biden did this let's see what the
results are
you're engaging in hyperbole and
non-thinking reactivity and so rich
lowry is right there's not going to be
unity
but not because joe biden is some
extreme progressive left winger
it's because 30 percent of this country
simply refuses to accept reality
and they have enough support among the
house and senate
that there will be actual elected
official republicans
who will do what they can to get in the
way of anything joe biden wants to do
and anything joe biden gets done they
will say
it's bad a priori and joe biden should
be punished because he's doing something
different than what republicans want him
to do
it's looking very ugly the good news is
it seems that democrats understand this
and bernie sanders understands this
and they are ready to simply pass things
by simple majority
ignoring republicans let's talk about
that next there's a very
interesting axios report that shows our
friend bernie sanders
understands they can't count on
republicans for a damn thing
and that he plans to push covet relief
and maybe more
through the senate with a simple
majority he was on cnn state of the
union yesterday talking about this
and uh he said they'll see about other
issues
with the coveted relief package proposed
by joe biden
which will top up the 600 payments to
2000 with an additional 1400
and expand unemployment benefits and do
a lot of other things
bernie sanders says it will be a simple
majority vote in the senate to get it
through
why is this so important uh this process
known as budget reconciliation
allows democrats to skip or circumvent
the 60-vote requirement that exists in
the senate
for many many legislative attempts
for many bills and if democrats are able
to
use budget reconciliation to rather than
need
60 votes in the senate which means
you've got to find 10 republican votes
50 with kamala harris harris's
tie-breaking vote would be enough
to get benefits to unemployed americans
uh to bolster unemployment benefits to
get that additional 1400
payment and uh what bernie sanders is
saying is really clear really pragmatic
and i love to see him saying this bernie
says quote
what we cannot do is wait weeks and
weeks and months to go forward we have
to act now
we're going to use reconciliation that's
50 votes in the senate
plus the vice president to pass this
legislation
and when he was asked if he wants a
relief bill passed
before trump's impeachment trial begins
in just a couple of weeks
he said we've got to do everything this
is not
you don't have time to sit around weeks
on
impeachment and not get vaccines into
the arms of people referring of course
to the additional vaccine funding in the
coronavirus stimulus
i think that this is absolutely the
right thing to do you don't
have to i mean listen we're going to be
having the conversation about the
filibuster
soon on the show and i've been reading a
lot about it many of you have been
saying talk about getting rid of the
filibuster or not
aside from that not only may democrats
have to do this
democrats will have to do this on a
number of issues
over the next couple of years they have
until the 2022 midterms
to show what it means to have a
democratic majority and what can be done
with it
if they waste it by letting the
republican party
poison the well on everything they want
to do
and obstruct the way we know republicans
are planning to do
it will actually make the case for
giving democrats
more seats in 22 very difficult to make
wait a second you had the house senate
and white house and you didn't get
anything done well
we needed 60 well but you could have
used budget reconciliation to get it
done with a simple majority
right but no it these are
unique times coming off of arguably the
worst presidency in modern american
history
during a mishandled global hundred year
pandemic
with an economic layer on top of the
medical layer
if there is ever a time to say guys you
know you
you marjorie taylor greens and lauren
boberts ted cruz and all these guys
who are who are still raising money from
these wacko cultist trumpists
um we just can't even deal with you guys
we're going to get things done
on our own and that's how ultimately
democrats will have to justify
re-election
in uh november of 2022. this is the idea
of getting rid of the filibuster this is
why mitch mcconnell is fighting it
because they want to do anything they
can to prevent democrats
from being able to pass things with a
simple majority budget reconciliation is
a way that they could do coveted relief
without getting 60 votes now on the
filibuster
there are arguments on both sides
if i if i'm sort of previewing my most
recent thought
i'm leaning towards being supportive of
getting rid of the filibuster that's not
what this conversation is about
this conversation is about passing
coveted relief
quickly i'm talking in the next 10 to 14
days
um without a 60 vote majority using
budget reconciliation now
it's important to remember budgets can't
be filibustered anything that is
allocations of money or lack thereof can
be passed without zero republican votes
there are other things whereas of right
now republicans can filibuster
if democrats decide we're going to do
this with a simple majority
republicans can't stop them i believe
this is the right decision
i'm glad to see bernie in this position
and i want to hear from you
where do you think this is going to lead
during the next two years find me on
twitter
at d pacman the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays i took their
quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that this program is primarily
funded by viewers and listeners like you
through the membership program you can
sign up in mere
seconds at joinpakman.com you'll get the
daily members only bonus show and the
pleasure
the true pleasure of knowing you're
supporting alternatives
to homogeneous corporate media you can
use the coupon code better21
if you so please to get a very large
discount
uh on the choice of membership that you
prefer
at joinpackman.com we have some very
interesting new polling from these early
days of the joe biden
administration and 69 percent of
americans approve
of joe biden's week one coveted response
and if you know anything about the
hyper partisan and politicized divided
nature of the united states 69
of americans agreeing about anything is
uh pretty remarkable and there are even
better numbers than that this is an abc
news ipsos poll released yesterday
69 of americans support joe biden's
19 response thus far that's 97
of democrats 70 percent of independents
but
very interestingly almost half of
republicans
40 percent of republicans approve of the
way joe biden
so far has handled coronavirus now
in comparison the highest approval rate
that trump ever had on the pandemic was
55 percent but when was it it was
mid-march what had trump done in
mid-march i think it was march 12th or
15th
that trump said we're shutting down
travel from china or europe
that was his high point of 55 and it's
only been down from there
joe biden already at 69
approval on coronavirus what has he done
so far that people approve of well on
day one he did sign the executive orders
he promised to sign
the federal face mask mandate at federal
buildings and on transportation
etc he also
put together a number of other specific
plans which are yet to be voted on
in terms of coronavirus stimulus vaccine
distribution
and much much more interestingly the
mask mandate
has 81 percent support across the
country 81
support and joe biden also importantly
stopped
the american withdrawal from the world
health organization
immediately putting dr anthony fauci as
the sort of liaison or spokesperson for
the us
in the rekindled relationship with the
who
70 of americans also agree with
getting back into or halting our exit
from
the w-h-o this is a really
really big deal um and the reason it's a
big deal
is that again in this country it's
really hard
to get numbers that high on anything if
you
you know we've talked before on
presidential approval
you have probably 20 percent of the
country who will never
abandon the president and 20 percent of
the country that will never approve of
the job the president's doing meaning
even though on paper a president's
approval could be between zero and 100
it's really probably between 20 and 80.
and
when we look at the data over recent
times about do you think trump really
won
the election the people who thought even
up until january 20th and maybe still
today
that somehow trump is going to get a
second term 30
of this country seems basically cuckoo
for cocoa puffs and i know some people
won't like that phrase but what i mean
is
there is a non-trivial portion of this
country 25
30 percent maybe that includes that 20
that will never abandon trump
plus another 5 to 10 percent that thinks
they are
evaluating the situation and coming to
those same conclusions
that is completely disconnected from
reality
completely disconnected from from
empiricism
and facts and thinking and rationality
and so when you see wow in a country
where 25 or 30 percent of the country is
whacked 81 percent approval
on a mask mandate that really tells you
something these are numbers that are
in practice effectively as close to
unanimity as you can expect to get in a
country that says ideologically
call it diverse as the united states
we also have from this new poll this abc
news ipsos poll
the question of do you believe joe biden
will unite the country now at the top of
the show i said no we're
what i see regardless of joe biden's
efforts i don't believe that we will
see a united united states in any true
sense
57 of respondents believe that joe biden
will make
progress in uniting the country not
a great number but it's something and
we will continue to track all of this
data we are starting to see
cases now as i predicted months ago this
isn't because of anything joe biden did
yet
we are starting to see cases come down
from their pandemic high
around january 10th and hopefully they
will continue on down
hopefully deaths will turn the corner
hospitalizations in many areas are
already going down so
let's hope that we continue in this
direction under joe biden
sadly dr deborah burks now retired
became an unfortunate node of
disinformation during her work
for the trump administration on the
coronavirus pandemic and you might
remember the clips of dr burke's
repeating how smart and thoughtful
donald trump is she would repeat
falsehoods about the reality of the
virus
she would make obviously false claims
about how well things are going here or
there
thanks to donald trump and many of us
did not fall forward although some did
now dr burks has retired and she did an
interesting interview yesterday with
cbs's face the nation and she sort of
came clean about the trump
administration's handling of coronavirus
and we're going to look at some [ __ ]
clips
not crips we're going to look at clips
and this is
all fine and good i mean she's telling
us things we all suspected
but it's too damn late the time to sound
the alarm would have been 10 months ago
when clearly she knew donald trump was
in over his head and this was being
mishandled coming clean
when trump's gone and you're retired and
we have two
soon to be three or even four vaccines
it's too late now it's still
interesting in a car crash sort of way
to hear what she has to say
asked if donald trump was merely
distracted from the virus which is
deadly enough
dr burke says there were actually people
in the white house
who actively thought the coronavirus
pandemic was a hoax
were there coveted deniers in the white
house
there are people in the white house and
i think people around this country
because i've had the privilege to meet
them
and listen to them and hear them because
i wanted to hear what people were saying
there were people who definitely
believed
that this was a hoax why
i think because the information was
confusing at the beginning
i think because we didn't talk about the
spectrum of disease
because everyone interpreted on what
they knew and so they saw people get
coveted
and be fine now she almost blames
herself there
we didn't talk about the spectrum of the
of disease
as if that would have changed the minds
of the people telling trump not to worry
about this
these were people committed for
political reasons to claiming or
believing that it was a hoax
and it's horrifying she presenting other
data
was not going to make a difference and
dr burks in this next clip claims
that despite the fact that she was the
coordinator of the white house covid
task force
she basically never saw trump in the
spring or
you gave an interview what we're seeing
today is different from march and april
it is extraordinarily widespread and
then president trump
tweeted he blasted you for saying that
did you ever speak to him
after that i hadn't seen him for months
before that
or months after that um but that was
like
that was the coordinator of the cove
attack that was an extraordinary moment
because i also
got yelled at by um
the speaker who i have tremendous i mean
obviously women have gone through a lot
to get in their positions i have
tremendous respect for women and women
leadership
speaker pelosi said she didn't have
confidence in you
because you were working for president
trump so i don't have confidence
anyone who stands there while the
president says uh swallow lysol
is going to cure your virus you know
he'll kill you and you won't have the
virus anymore and so that was very hard
because i've known her from the hiv
world
so again the big news berks hadn't seen
trump
in person for months before that nor
after that covet coordinator not seeing
the president of the united states
trump simply didn't care which we knew
she's just confirming it
uh berks asked how the hell did trump
get covered
arguably the person who could be the
most protected they were supposedly
testing everybody every day
and dr burke says nobody at the white
house wore a mask take a listen to this
but how did the task force allow the
president who calls himself a germaphobe
to get covet himself how did that happen
there were only two people who regularly
wore a mask in the white house
myself and tyler ann mcguffrey the
support person
that i had from hhs so the staff around
the president was not wearing a mask
he's the commander-in-chief this is a
national security risk
how is that possible i think people
believed
wrongly that testing
testing would be adequate how is that
possible i think they believe that
testing
is a surrogate for a public health
intervention but did you say the
president of the united states needs to
wear a mask
did you press mike pence on that did you
press mark meadows as chief of staff
there are multiple communications about
masking yeah
this tells you a lot and and again we
suspected this stuff
but to hear her say it is both again too
little too late
but stunning to hear that this degree of
incompetence surrounded trump
um here she explains that someone was
giving trump graphs that weren't coming
from her
she doesn't know who it was but somebody
was giving trump other data but
and by data i mean pictures essentially
do you think president trump appreciated
the gravity of the health crisis you
were describing
i think the president appreciated the
gravity in march
it took a while after i arrived in the
white house
to remove all of the answer larry data
that was coming in
i mean there was parallel data streams
coming
into the white house that were not
transparently utilized and i needed to
stop that
where you mean outside advisors outside
advisors coming to inside advisors
and to this day i mean until the day i
left i am
i'm convinced there were parallel data
streams because i disinformation
i saw the president presenting graphs
that i never made
so i know that someone or
someone out there or someone inside was
creating
a parallel set of data and graphics that
were shown to the president
i don't know to this day who parallel
data and strange graphs and charts
huh not unique to the pandemic
within the trump administration i think
we all remember the hurricane
sharpie incident and other instances of
bogus data and graphs
so all of our suspicions were true
and that's why this happened early trump
didn't take it seriously
after april he also didn't and no one at
the white house
did uh that was in his immediate inner
circle
the people taking it seriously like dr
burks
to some degree although she did play a
role in in perpetuating disinformation
dr
fauci they weren't even talking to
donald trump for months at a time and
there were people
at the white house who believed it was a
hoax
this is the full story and it explains
everything that went on perfectly
clearly they uh disbanded the pandemic
response team
they threw out or ignored the pandemic
response playbook left behind
color-coded by the obama administration
they weren't wearing masks at the white
house they weren't talking to dr burke's
trump wasn't and burke's coming clean
now is great for the record
but it didn't help at all back then the
if
is there a silver lining here there is
knowing the degree of uh
of disregard that the trump
administration had for the virus
and seeing how joe biden is actually
taking this issue head on from day one
suggests
to me as if we didn't know from all of
the examples from new zealand and rwanda
and taiwan and others
that having a federal administration
focus focused on this will make a really
big difference like things got
disastrously bad in the us
and they got that bad with total
incompetence and disregard from the
trump administration
uh now that we have people paying
attention to it i am even more confident
that it will make a huge difference
could dr berks and dr fauci and someone
else maybe have come together in may
and publicly denounced everything that
was going on
yeah maybe i don't know and and again
the question that i have is
i don't know what happens if they do if
they all get fired
and get replaced with total sycophants
burke's kind of became a sycophant by by
exclude by by default
fauci did not but he was pushed out to a
great degree
i don't know if they all come together
and say this has to stop this is what's
going on they may all get fired
and and get replaced by the equivalent
of uh dr scott atlas in all of these
positions but
nothing surprising whatsoever in what dr
debra burks tells us would have been
nice
for her to say it a little bit sooner
for sure we'll have more coverage of
this on our instagram
page you can find us on instagram at
davidpakmanshow
and you can find me on instagram at
david.pacman
i posted some interesting things over
the weekend that you may find
enjoyable or horrifying depending on
your
predisposition quick break back after
this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right so we're going to look at some
material today from
two of these new republican members of
the u.s house who were elected
in november today we're going to be
looking at an interview with republican
congressman madison
cawthorne and shortly we're going to
look at some tweets from republican
congresswoman lauren
beaubert and here's what i really want
everyone to get from this among
uh yes how to identify and defeat really
bad arguments that's important but
there's a bigger story here
these people whose material we're going
to look at momentarily
they got elected riding the trump scam
train they didn't run on policy
they didn't run on being experts in a
particular
issue or on certain types of subject
matter they ran
on merely playing trumpian characters
riding the wave of support for trumpism
that exists to a greater degree in some
parts of the country and in some
districts in the united states
and the problem with electing what are
essentially characters
playing a political acting role is they
don't know anything about anything
there's no substance to them whatsoever
now in general in american politics
there's a huge role
for personality you all know this
personality appearance
uh public speaking ability ability to
raise money there's a whole bunch of
stuff that in american politics on both
sides
it can get people elected who are not
the most qualified and doesn't mean
they're actually equipped to deal with
policy in depth
but this has never been more acutely so
than among this latest wave of people
who got elected merely for being
pro-trump cultists in areas
that have a lot of pro-trump cultist
voters so let's get right into this new
republican congressman madison cawthorne
has been very loudly saying first of all
that he goes armed to the house of
representatives
but also that there was likely fraud and
wrongdoing
in states like georgia arizona
pennsylvania and others
because of mail-in voting and other
stuff that trump
has also been repeating you all know the
stories
it took two months between the election
and the inauguration two and a half
months
of them repeating these same bogus tired
stories
and kawthorne actually voted against
accepting
certain states election results in the
house of representatives on january 6th
so kawthorne goes on cnn and he's
interviewed by pamela brown who came
very prepared
and is asked about the fact that his
arguments for voting not to certify
some states apply to the state in which
he was elected north carolina as well
but
he never claimed that there were
problems in his state
even though the guidelines he has a
problem with in other states
apply just as much to north carolina
this go
this could not have gone any worse for
madison cawthorne he's going to have to
stop doing these interviews
but before we get to that part here's
pamela brown
challenging madison cawthorne to cite
evidence of election fraud she
says and i love this you must have so
many specific instances of
of of evidence of fraud right and he did
not what are some specific
examples that informed this bold
decision this audacious decision even
after the riots to
decertify the results you must have seen
some concrete evidence
well pam the things that i was not
objecting to the election on behalf of
was things like dominion voting machines
changing ballots or these u-haul trucks
pulling up filled with
ballots for joe biden as president the
thing i was objecting for is
things like in like i said in the state
of wisconsin particularly in the town of
madison
there was a an appointed official in
that town who actually went against the
will
of the state legislature and created
ballot drop boxes which is
basically ballot harvesting that was
happening in the parks but this was all
litigated
you know that the trump campaign
litigated all of this
more than 60 cases and they lost either
the cases were dismissed the trump
campaign
withdrew or they never brought a case
because they didn't have the evidence to
back it up
indeed i believe specifically and this
is the one that i debated on behalf of
on the house floor in wisconsin
that was never heard because they
dismissed it because of standing
now i don't believe that that is a
concrete enough well there were three
trump appointments okay so you have
wisconsin but you never you ended up not
actually
voting against wisconsin it was just
arizona and pennsylvania because you
didn't have the senate votes
um but okay so he didn't object because
of machines
or massive ballot dumps coming out of
the back of trucks okay
but in wisconsin some official created
drop boxes
but as pamela brown points out that was
all litigated
it had no merit but the most important
is he keeps talking about wisconsin
he didn't end up voting against
certification in wisconsin he voted
against certification in other states
this is so incoherent we'd need an hour
to tease it all apart
and it gets even worse three trump
appointed judge
actually threw out these cases because
of merit it was because of merit there
were three
trump appointed judges out of all of
these judges and the more than 60 cases
that were tossed out you
keep talking about wisconsin i'm still
not hearing any specific examples of
fraud if you would
just tell us what are the specific
examples you saw a fraud because
when you think of fraud you think of a
vote you're slipping one past the
election official or a vote was stolen
somehow it didn't count did you see that
specifically
no pam and like i said that's not the
reason i contested the election
so this is already just a disaster for
this guy
and then pamela brown points out the
contradiction between kawthorne saying
he has issues with the changes to
election rules in wisconsin
where his own state where he was elected
north carolina
made similar changes because of the
pandemic look at this this
if you have an aversion to cringe walk
out of the room right now
keep focusing on was focusing on
wisconsin but there were several
battleground states
that you contested to that you talked
about there were several
that president trump had lost so it's
interesting you're focusing on wisconsin
but would you apply the same issues you
had with these battleground states to
your own state
of north carolina because north carolina
also changed a lot of the rules
even after voters had started voting why
didn't you have concerns about your own
home state of north carolina
well you know pam i'm actually not aware
of the laws that were changed inside of
north carolina i believe we had a very
safe and a very secure election here
uh oh wait wait north carolina was fine
safe
secure even though they did lots of the
same things
but north carolina simply didn't become
part of the narrative
and it keeps getting even worse if you
can imagine
so there's no reason to contest that
yeah there were several rules
one of which is to extend when the
mainland ballots could arrive i
i believe by around seven days that was
one and there were a couple of others as
well
um that that were changed even after
people
started voting so i'm just wondering if
you're so concerned about
the you know these rules being changed
with the election
why why wouldn't you focus on your own
home state of north carolina i mean
you're telling me that your concern
really
is about election integrity not politics
not the results of the election right
that is absolutely correct i didn't do
this for any one man or against any one
man
okay so north carolina though the same
issues you've had and you've expressed
about the battleground states
those are the same issues that are in
your own state of north carolina and
north carolina actually did have mail
and ballot fraud in 2018. so
so you're not concerned about your home
state and whether you were duly elected
by your own standards
well i'll tell you because of the
mail-in ballot fraud that happened in
the midterms here in 2018
i believe our election integrity
standards here in north carolina
are some of the greatest in the country
i i think they should apply this metric
all over the country but that's just my
opinion
so he doesn't know anything about it or
at least claims to but it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter his election was
definitely accurate
because he won so he definitely won fair
and square
and then later in the sort of wrap up to
this complete
farce of an interview he admits yeah the
election wasn't fraudulent i did what i
do what i could do to push back
but it actually was not a fraudulent
election well so but then madison why
did you push back
can you now say that the election was
not stolen that it wasn't a fraudulent
election
yes i think i would say that the
election was not fraudulent um
you know i the the constitution allowed
for us to be able to push back as much
as we could and i did that to the
amount of the constitutional limits that
i had at my disposal so now i would say
that joseph r biden is our president
and you have no regrets no i do not have
any regrets
okay listen republican congressman
madison cawthorn thank you for coming on
so either he's going to need some
serious media training
or he will have to stop doing these
interviews and this
is what happens when we elect characters
to play lawmakers on tv it's not about
governing it's the new version of
winning a reality tv show that's all it
is and
pamela brown so easily dismantles this
guy
to the point of it being humiliating for
him and you almost start to feel bad for
the kid
except that he chose to do this and
people voted him in
and now he can wield power and do a lot
of damage so
it isn't necessarily a new phenomenon
in our political history that
incompetent people get elected that's
not new and we've seen that on both
sides
but the way in which the cult of trump
has been weaponized to propel completely
clueless people who have no business
even being on the house floor like it's
not even about what they do
they have no business being on the house
floor their big concern is bringing guns
to the house floor
um it is particularly pernicious right
now now contrast this
if you want to think about someone who's
the opposite of people like madison
cawthorne and lauren bobert who we'll
talk about
think about jamie raskin okay you don't
have to agree with everything jamie
raskin does
you can say jamie raskin is not
progressive enough or whatever jamie
raskin is a guy who cares about policy
and depth and brings a depth of
knowledge about the issues
and he can talk about the he is a sort
of politician's politician and he
suffered tragic loss recently
with the death of of one of his children
but
he comes to mind as the antithesis
to these clueless reality show
characters let's now talk about
lauren bober we're continuing our tour
through truly incompetent new trumpy
members of the house
and congresswoman lauren beaubert
is at the top of the list along with
marjorie taylor greene
and madison cawthorne and as you may or
may not know
lauren beaubert demands to be armed on
the house floor
she recently set off the metal detectors
at the house of representatives it this
is a this is a wacky wacky person
she tweeted something which exposed her
complete lack of knowledge about the
minimum wage and economics
she said quote i got my start working at
mcdonald's
that job doesn't exist if the minimum
wage is raised to 15 dollars per hour
small business would be crushed by this
arbitrary mandate and big business would
simply automate away
jobs not everything that sounds good
is actually good in practice it is
stunning
how many bad arguments she was able to
squeeze into that one tweet first of all
she claims jobs at mcdonald's don't
exist
if you raise the minimum wage to fifteen
dollars per hour minimum wage in
washington dc
is fifteen dollars per hour mcdonald's
exist
debunked number two she says that it's
arbitrary to make the minimum wage
fifteen dollars an hour this is an
argument we often hear from people who
come in and say
listen if you're just picking a number
and more money for people is good
why stop at fifteen dollars an hour make
the minimum wage a hundred dollars an
hour
make it a thousand dollars an hour and
of course
they are wrong that it is arbitrary a a
hundred or a thousand
uh dollar an hour minimum wage is not
defensible
on the basis of cost of living on the
basis of
work and productivity generated by
employees
in typical minimum wage jobs it's not an
equilibrium wage
in the market so they want to say oh
it's our
15 bucks it could be 12 it could be a
hundred make it a thousand why not no no
no
there's nothing arbitrary about it and
15 is probably
a hair too low in some places due to
cost of living
and in in some other places you could
argue
there are really low cost of living
places where maybe you could argue 15 is
too high relative to cost of living and
and revenue at small businesses but
the idea that it's arbitrary is just
completely wrong
and uh what what you have to understand
what is she missing here and she's
missing a lot
remember that labor is only one
input at a place like mcdonald's and
we've studied
how meaningful wage increases at places
like mcdonald's
would have a very small impact on the
total cost
not the price the cost of a big mac
and clueless people have scammed their
way
into positions of power by attaching
themselves to the trump scam train and
republican voters fell for it
and now you have people like lauren
bobert who don't know anything
in positions of power you also have to
remember
that when you increase the minimum wage
you're creating demand side stimulus
even though it might cost mcdonald's a
little more to make the big mac
because of the increased minimum wage
way more people
now have money to go buy more big macs
that's the demand side
stimulus component she also mentions
they would automate jobs
mcdonald's has already been doing that
for a very long time both in areas where
there is a fifteen dollar minimum wage a
fourteen dollar minimum wage a thirteen
dollar minimum wage
and a seven dollar minimum wage they've
already been automating these touch
screen
ordering machines app-based delivery and
collection or you know all this
different stuff
um and so it of course it's a total
misunderstanding by lauren bobert
i don't think anyone's shocked that she
doesn't know a damn thing about
economics
but the reality is that we're only going
to get more of this if at some point
the republican party doesn't say we have
to
this has to stop even people like you
know okay
i would disagree with mitt romney on
policy
but he has a better understanding of at
least
what the terms of the debate are and how
it should be discussed
we would come to different conclusions
he would have some bad ideas i'm sure
about supply-side
economics as an example but this is just
a cartoonish farce people like lauren
bobert and if the republican party
learned
anything from the trump fiasco it would
be to make sure that in the 2022
election
all of these nuts lose that and i don't
know that republicans have actually
learned that
let me know if you think they have we'll
be back right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous
at this point and the daily commercial
free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we're continuing to get to know this new
class of elected officials
in the house of representatives which
includes some
really really unqualified people we've
spoken before about marjorie taylor
greene who
drafted articles of impeachment against
joe biden on january 21st last week yes
she did
we talked earlier today about lauren
bobert
we spoke earlier today about madison
cawthorne's disastrous interview on cnn
you know to give you a sense of the sort
of folks that we're dealing with here
um there is pretty widespread reporting
about
madison cothorn visiting hitler's house
because it was a bucket list
item for him and everything about i mean
down to the detail
this is indistinguishable from satire
with some of these guys
um the jewish mayor of asheville north
carolina remember that madison cawthorne
is a representative now in north
carolina back in august
said it's very concerning that the
republican
then candidate now member of congress
visited adolf hitler's vacation home
and referred to him as the fuhrer on
social media
and back in 2017 cawthorne posted from
the so-called
eagle's nest hitler's vacation home it
was one of the last battlegrounds of
world war
ii referred to hitler as the fuhrer
said that going there was on his bucket
list
and did call hitler a supreme evil right
i i'm not
looking to hide that from you
the mayor manheimer said it's very
concerning
throughout the last several years since
trump has been elected president
i think all of us have seen that white
supremacists
are emboldened and are publicly making
their positions known
and to elect someone who openly throws
out dog whistles like this
it just makes me really sad actually
first and foremost
it makes me sad disappointed worried now
when this
was written about kawthorne briefly took
down the pictures because
a lot of attention was called to them
then they were publicly visible again
kawthorne deciding to double down and to
say that it's a fake news controversy
that he wasn't there to celebrate he was
celebrating
a victory over evil so i have a few
different
thoughts about this first of all as
someone who
who is disabled madison cawthorne would
have been one of the first killed by the
nazis right after jews
so that the irony of that is certainly
not
lost on me you'll very often hear
defenses from
these folks like no i was interested in
seeing how such
evil was defeated or sometimes you'll
hear a little more about
well it was interesting for historical
reasons visiting hitler's vacation home
historian and it was interesting for
that or reading mineconf is interesting
for historical reasons um i enjoy
history as well
but when you see people flocking
to the hitler stuff for history's sake
but they're not interested in any other
areas of history
it is a little weird right like if
mineconf is the only history book you
read
you might not be that interested in
history and mineconf isn't even really a
history book it's a historical book for
sure but it's not a book about history
i'm no expert but very often when people
gravitate to hitler's vacation home or
reading mind confident like that's the
only curiosity they have
it's not really about history it's that
they find the legacy of power and
violence
and ruthlessness exciting or interesting
and it's
i'm not denying that madison cawthorn
thinks hitler was
evil in some kind of nominal way
uh what i am sure of is that kawthorne
is a reactionary and a liar and we
should be very careful about believing
anything he says and i don't know how
many of you
are aware of the history of lying
madison cawthorne
misled the public about claiming he was
training for the paralympics
he misrepresented his educational
history he misrepresented his business
history
this seems like just a liar which
reminds me of someone by the way
multiple outlets have reported that
before running for office kawthorne said
he was training
for the 2020 paralympic games
there's no evidence of that whatsoever
corn wasn't on
any team or club he didn't run
any races it'd sort of be like if i said
i'm training for olympic ski jumping
but have you done any skiing to prepare
no do you have a coach
no are you on any team no
do you have a lift ticket anywhere no
but i'm training like that's the degree
to which it seems that he was training
corn claims to have been a successful
business owner
and uh heading to the naval academy when
his
tragic car accident left him paralyzed
but
the truth is he had already been
rejected from the naval academy so it
wasn't true he was heading there
his only business that anyone was able
to find was a real estate investment
company
that had zero income and no employees
in 2019 so this seems like a liar and
when you talk about someone that gets
elected
merely riding uh riding the wings or
standing on the coattails of donald
trump in the trump cult
this is exactly who you would imagine
gets elected and we'll be doing deep
dives into lauren beaubert we'll be
doing deep dives into marjory taylor
green
these are folks who know nothing about
policy or governance they are the
epitome
of cultish role players and we saw that
in madison cawthorne's
pamela brown interview earlier on in the
show and so
these folks really have to be defeated
in 2022.
if republicans learned anything from
trumpy and the trumpian fiasco and i
don't know that they have but as i said
earlier
if they learned anything from the
trumpian fiasco
they would make sure to run credible
primaries against these folks
or to convince them to retire and that
they can't win
i don't know that that's actually going
to happen but these folks if they get
re-elected would cement this trumpian
cult
um in the house of representatives from
multiple terms and that would be really
really scary and an absolutely horrible
thing
hey listen to this this is just a
pleasure to read rudy giuliani is being
sued by dominion
voting systems over false election
claims
the lawsuit against rudy giuliani
is because he is accused of carrying out
a quote viral disinformation campaign
dominion voting systems has filed a
defamation lawsuit the lawsuit was filed
this morning and it's 107 pages long it
accuses
not only giuliani as i mentioned of
carrying out a viral disinformation
campaign
about dominion it accuses him of uh
putting out their demonstrably false
allegations to enrich himself through
legal fees and his podcast and that's
true
a big theme on his popular podcast for
rudy giuliani was making false claims
about dominion voting systems the suit
is suing rudy for 1.3 billion dollars
yeah
they're not going to get that i know and
it makes
um these uh it files this suit on the
basis of 50 different statements that
rudy made
at legislative hearings via tweets as
well as on his podcast and while being
interviewed on conservative news media
now as you know
rudy giuliani was supposedly getting 20
grand a day to defend donald trump or
represent donald trump in the election
fraud
bogus cases we later learned that donald
trump
directed his team not to pay rudy
giuliani and we don't know
if for how much of that 20 grand a day
rudy has actually been able to collect
but look at this does anybody feel sorry
for rudy
you throw your reputation away to peddle
baseless conspiracy theories for trump
which of course go nowhere trump ends up
saying
don't pay him and now rudy is going to
accumulate
significant legal fees because he's
getting sued for the things that he said
now
he should be sued he should be disbarred
and in the end he should be held
accountable
for his role in the insurrection which
now i don't just mean
on the day of the insurrection saying
let's do trial by combat that's bad
enough
but i mean the two and two months that
he spent
ginning up anger over non-existent voter
fraud claims with his hearings and his
flatulence at the hearings and
everything else and you can
actually make the case that dominion
voting systems
has really been irreparably damaged by
the false allegations
it is hard to think of a time where i
would take the side of a corporation
against an individual
but the dominion voting system's name
any election that dominion voting
systems is involved in
you are going to have people who come
out of the woodwork and claim fraud
because of dominion voting systems
these people rudy giuliani and sydney
powell
and and lynn wood and whoever they
really have
destroyed the reputation of dominion
voting systems for no reason whatsoever
so
we'll see what happens uh in these
lawsuits
in terms of rudy listen um
a lot of people continue to say rudy was
just compromised that's why rudy did all
of these things
he was compromised we don't yet know the
full extent or the details but he was
if borat can get rudy into the position
rudy found himself
in there's no doubt that professionals
would be able to manipulate rudy
giuliani there's no question about that
and um when you think about it a lot of
the actions from some of these
republicans
can be explained by them being
compromised i'm not saying
they are but for example lauren beaubert
owed or owes money to the irs
that would often prevent people from
getting a security clearance
but politicians are still able to run
and get elected regardless
and it puts her in a position of being
very easy to have over a barrel
if the right people get involved rudy
again rudy throwing away his reputation
had strong
favorability as the mayor of new york
city after 9 11.
and that went away over the following
years
and then just completely imploding in
terms of his reputation
during the presidency of donald trump
now by the way
this should be exciting news for anybody
who still believes there was evidence of
election fraud this lawsuit what do i
mean by that
if the lawsuit goes forward the
evidence that rudy giuliani and his
cronies
supposedly have about dominion voting
systems
would come out in the discovery phase of
the lawsuit so for those of you and i
know that there are some of you still in
my audience who think
any day now the evidence will come out
this lawsuit against rudy
is the perfect opportunity to get all of
that evidence of voter fraud out during
the discovery phase
i'll be waiting i look forward to seeing
if we ever see that information
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
uh here's something we heard from troy
york you know i'm hearing this from a
lot of people which is basically now
that trump is gone
your show is dead david it's dead
you know just uh i bet secretly you had
to be rooting for president trump
because
i think that you as a podcaster uh you
are done
right i mean if you don't have trump
around what the hell is the david padman
show going to talk about
and you're not gonna get your
international funding anymore there's no
point in
right funding which i don't have
programs like you
david pacman and sam cedar you guys are
done
right so i don't know why you celebrate
and we're
pushing so hard against trump when in
fact you're not going to have no content
right you know what's fascinating about
this is that when obama
won and defeated george w bush i got all
the same emails
you're now on the inside and it's not
going to be there's not going to be
nothing to do
the show quadrupled during obama raised
venture capital i mean it was it was
like crazy the obama era was completely
crazy for us but i got worried
troy maybe troy's on to something here
maybe we're done
so i went and looked and in the short
five day period since the inauguration
we had live stream views in the millions
we continued to have one or even two
million views a day on the youtube
channel even through the weekend when we
normally see a dip
we added 11 000 new youtube subscribers
uh and one of the biggest growth weeks
we've ever had on our instagram
ig tv channel was uh the last week
uh during and since the inauguration and
you know the the reality is
there are always things going on right
wing media is going to be nuts the next
two years
these trumpian right-wing elected
officials are going to be nuts and some
of our best performing clips of the last
three months and during the last three
months trump did a lot of crazy things
even during the last three months and
in the have been since the time of
trump's departure
our coverage of lauren beaubert and
these other insurrectionists the focus
group with republican voters
one of our top clips sean hannity
claiming biden's doing
re-education camps this this has been a
thing forever you're circling the drain
now that the winds are changing
politically
and then we grow and we grow and we grow
and if the last five days are any
indication
the next three months could be really
crazy but you know i'm really glad that
through the years
troy has stuck with us he seems to love
the show
because he knows everything that's going
on here we will talk to you more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member at joinpackman.com
we will talk about the death of larry
king
we will talk about the candidacy of
sarah huckabee sanders
for governor of arkansas and much much
more
sign up and get instant access at
joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors steadymd lets you
maintain a meaningful long-lasting
relationship with a primary care
physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started